- Hello, welcome.
We'll give a minute for people to arrive.
I see some familiar faces and names.
Welcome back to those of you
who've been here through the series.
Good, well, I'm Paul North.
I teach at Yale and I'm teaching a seminar
on Capital, Volume I, an
undergraduate seminar,
and this lecture series has
been going along with it.
It is the Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
at the Whitney Humanity Center.
It's called "The Value of Marx's Capital."
And it's also a place where my colleague,
Paul Reitter, and I can
learn a lot about capital
in the frame of doing a new
translation of Volume I.
Paul is doing that.
So I need to thank the Franke family
and say that the Franke
Lectures are made possible
by the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Franke,
and they're intended to
present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide and general audience.
I wanna thank, as I
always do, Alice Kaplan,
the director of the
Whitney Humanity Center
for making this possible
in a special circumstance,
the pandemic.
Thank you to Sandra Malan-Bowles
and Leana Hirschfeld-Kroen
for doing all the logistics
and organization with speakers.
This is the last moment
I can thank everyone,
this being the last session.
So thanks to them, especially,
for all the work they did,
and to Audrey Leak, our
great tech assistant.
Thank you, Audrey.
After this, you can just
go back to your break.
So, thank you.
We're gonna have the presentation,
and then after that,
questions, as we always do.
I'll ask you just to hold your questions
until after the presentation
so we can follow them easily in the chat.
Please put them in the chat
and then we will open your
mic as close as we can
to the order of your
questions in the chat.
Now, I'm going to give the
mic over to Paul Reitter
to introduce our speaker.
- Thanks, Paul, and thanks
everyone for being here
since this is our last session.
Let me just say that I wanna thank
all the regular attendees for coming.
We've had some real stalwarts here
and I think the participation
has been really wonderful.
I've learned a lot from
following these discussions.
Paul and I, when we set this
up, mostly Paul set it up,
I think didn't have
very clear expectations.
And so, of course, our
expectations have been surpassed
in one way or another, but
here they've been surpassed
in a very good way and it's
been a great experience.
So thank and thank you to Audrey and Guy
for all the support.
It's been great and it's also been great
getting to know you a little bit.
And thank you, Cinzia, for being here.
I'm now gonna introduce you briefly.
Cinzia is a Professor of Philosophy
at The New School and
she is a Cinzia Arruzza.
She's a Professor of
Philosophy at The New School
and she is by training an
expert on ancient philosophy
and has worked extensively
on Plato and Neoplatonism,
she is in fact, also a translator
she's translated volume by Plotinus.
So I wanted to of course,
mark that and appreciate it.
Knowing as I do something
about the labor of translation
and how in fact labor-intensive
it is she's the author
and editor of many books.
I'll just read a couple of
titles here, Dangerous Liaisons
Marriages and Divorces of
Marxism and Feminism Philosophy
and Political Power and Antiquity.
This is a co-edited volume,
A Wolf in the City Tyranny
and The Tyrant and Plato's Republic.
This is a book that she
authored that came out in 2018
with Oxford University
Press, and then The Highly
impactful Feminism for
the 99% of Manifesto
which she co-authored
with Nancy Fraser and also
Tithi Bhattacharya who was
here and gave a presentation
in the series, which was really wonderful.
And this book had touched
off of a big debate.
That's got a tremendous
amount of attention
and is a powerful work a manifesto.
It lives up to its subtitle fully.
So thank you so much for being here.
And the presentation today
is on readings in misreadings
of primitive accumulation.
So welcome Cinzia
- Thank you very much
for this introduction.
And also for obviously for inviting me
I'm aware this is the last lecture
of the series at least this semester.
So I feel a bit of performance anxiety
because we need to
conclude the serious well
so I will try to do so
but bear with me because I will try,
within an hour to go over a fair amount
of conceptual issues concerning
primitive accumulation
and also debates.
And as the title says
readings and misreadings
of primitive accumulation
and I would like to start by saying
that primitive accumulation
is one of the most debated
and probably controversial
topics in Marxist theory.
And this has to do with
the fact that depending
on interpretation of these pages
so primitive accumulation, we
have a relevant consequences
on a political and analytical
level on various fronts.
So for example, we have consequences
for the analysis of historical transition
to capitalism and how
we interpret the problem
of transition the nature of
a historical development.
So for example, one of the
worries around the interpretation
of primitive accumulation
has to do with the the risk
of falling into the
theological philosophies
of history and therefore
have you over necessary
historical development.
Another area that has to do
with the debates of primitive
accumulation has to do,
they're all of direct,
extra economic violence
within capitalist and
capitalist accumulation.
And finally, obviously the the question
that absolutely controversial question
of the relationship between
gender racial oppression
and capitalism and
capitalism accumulation.
Moreover depending on
what analysis we give
and what reading we give
of primitive accumulation, we also have,
we get different pictures of the way
in which capitalism works and the way
in which capitalism is distinct
or not distinct from
other modes of production.
So is this is something that
is really specific peculiar
to capitalist is compared
to other modes of production
or forms of sociality.
So, off course not address all
of these problems in one single lecture
But what I'm going to try
to do is to give first
a reading of primitive accumulation.
So in other words, a general
overview or what happens
in this in Part VIII in
section eight of capital volume
one in the English edition.
And then I will discuss the two main
lines of contemporary debates
and readings of primitive accumulation.
The first one concerns
whether primitive accumulation
should be considered
as a fact of the past.
So as the past of capitalism
on whether we should that rather speak
of an ongoing primitive accumulation
that repeats constantly itself
within capitalist societies
the second debate concerns
what I already mentioned
that is the issue of violence
and race and their relation
to capitalist accumulation
and I know that some of the lectures
that proceeded me have already touched
upon this topic, especially
the role of slavery
and the transatlantic slay
market for for capitalism.
So I will try to address also this debate.
Okay, so let's start with
what our prints in Part VIII
of Capital Volume I
and also why Marx rights
Part VIII of Capital Volume I
on primitive accumulation.
The first thing I want
to underline to stress
has to do with the fact
that the discussion
of primitive accumulation takes place
at the end of Volume I,
not at the beginning.
So in other words, we do
have the marches on take
on historical processes
that led to the emergence
of capitalism in Europe, not
at the beginning of a capital
not as a prelude to capital,
but rather at the end.
Now, why is this the case I take it
that it may have to do
with what Marx writes
in the (Mumbles) in terms
of how do read history.
In other words, it is
only after the neurologic
or capitalist accumulation
has been developed
has been expanded upon
and explained in its key
and most abstract aspects
that is possible to then
give a presentation of the
historical process that led
to the emergence of capitalism.
So in other words, the key
for the interpretation of
the past is our present.
So it is only in light
of our understanding
and analysis of the reality of
contemporary social relations
or production that we can
probably understand the serious
of seemingly disjoint historical process,
historical events and historical facts
as actually a process
leading to an outcome.
And the outcome is of
course our own reality.
So for this reason, I think,
or at least this is one
of the reasons I think why Part VIII
is at the end of Capital Volume I.
So as you may have noticed
I do think that Part VIII
has to do with the origin
the problem of the origin
and the emergence of capital.
And that fully does fundamentally to do
with the problem or transition
I'm going to emphasize
and insist on this because
as I will explain later on
in a contemporary debates
about periods of accumulation
this element of transition is often lost
in attempts to basically
read primitive accumulation
as an ongoing process.
Now, what is Marx’s problem here?
He explains his problem
at the very beginning of the section.
The problem is that throughout
Volume I Marx has shown
how capital is a self reproducing
model production governed
by its own inner logic
which is the logical
valorization of value.
So once in existence,
capital basically constantly
posits itself as its own presupposition.
So capital generates capital
through the exploitation of
labor power live in labor.
And so it's expansion now
on an increased scale is the there mean
by the inner tendencies or capital itself.
So let's say that in a sense
capital moves in a circuit
or with a circular motion
but of course, expanding at each circuit.
Now, if we take this to
be inner logical capital
so self-organizing value
and so on now we end up
with a problem, which is that this logic
cannot be used to explain
the emergence of capitalism.
So in other words, if once
capital is in existence
capital posits itself as
its own pursuit position
this cannot be true for
the historical emergence
of capital, because otherwise
we end up into circular reasoning.
So to summarize the problem
in the clearest possible terms
Marx needs to provide an account
of the emergence of capital.
That first does not Eben
that ended up in sequel
or reasoning by setting
capital as the historical
original capital.
And secondly, it needs to
also highlight the originality
peculiarity and specificity of capital
with regard to other modes of
production and forms of life
which also were based and
are based on exploitation
and domination.
So what is it that makes
capitalism or capital
the kind of bloodthirsty
monster that it is
compared to other oppressive
modes of production.
Now the first problem
which is a logical problem.
So basically how to avoid the ending
up in an infinite regress
or circular reasoning
and so on was already
addressed by Adam Smith
in Wealth of Nations,
where Adam Smith postulated
that at the origin of capitalism
there must have been some
previous accumulation
of what he calls stocks
or stocks of capital.
However, Smith doesn't
really address this issue
in historical terms, but
rather in logical ones.
So in other words, it
is logical prerequisite
to avoid circular reasoning to postulate
a previous accumulation of stocks
but how these stocks were
accumulated is actually
not specified historically by Smith.
And this allows Smith
to base, to offer a sort
of he didn't leak as Marx would say,
non-violent original myth.
I came to what Marx calls,
The Myth of the Original sin
of Adam and Eve.
Now I'm going to share my screen hoping
that everything will work.
Yeah. Okay.
So here is the original
sin passage from Volume I.
This primitive accumulation
plays approximately
the same role in political
economy as original sin does
in theology.
Adam bit the apple and thereupon
sin fell on the human race.
It's origin is supposed to
be explain when it is told
as an anecdote about
the past long, long ago
there were two sorts of people
one the diligent intelligent,
and above all frugal elite,
the other lazy rascals spending
their substance and more riotous living.
So while Marx agrees with
the logical necessity
of postulating, a previous
accumulation of stocks
as a the point of
departure for capitalism,
he also challenges the
idyllic presentation
of the concrete historical
process that enabled
the accumulation of these period stocks.
Moreover, and this is
quite a crucial point
Marx also intends to show
that again, the accumulation
of previous stocks is
a necessary condition,
but not a sufficient one
for explaining the historical
emergency of capitalism.
And so something else, must be part
of the equation.
plunder, conquest, robbery,
and murder have characterized
most of human history at
least when we speak about
class societies in particular
in this direct forms of domination
and violence can not alone
explain what is distinctive
about capitalism with regard
to other modes of production.
So, in other words Marx is here looking
for the missing element in the explanation
of the historical emergence of capitalism.
And this missing element
has to do with that deep
profound transformation
in class relations.
Let's see the next slide.
No, Oh God.
Yes, here.
This is the slide I was looking for.
So as he writes "in themselves
money and commodities are no more capital
than the means of production
and of subsistence are.
They need to be transformed into capital
but this transformation
can itself only take place
under particular circumstances,
which meet together
at this point.
The confrontation of and contact
between two very different
kinds of commodity owners.
On the one hand, the owners
of money means of production
means of subsistence
who are eager to valorize
the sum of values
they have appropriated by buying
the labor-power of others.
On the other hand, free workers
the sellers of their own labor-power
and therefore the sellers of labor.
(faintly speaking)
Okay.
So with this two concepts in mind.
So in other words, the
fact that Marx wants to
on the one hand challenge
the idyllic myth of the
original capitalism.
On the other hand
he wants also to show what is
distinctive about capitalism.
So what is the allows the transformation
of money and commodities into capital.
I'm going to give a very brief summary
of the main points of a Marxist arguments.
And I would like to start
this by insisting on the fact
that Marx is here talking
about what do you call it?
The classical example of
primitive accumulation
that is how primitive
accumulation concretely
took place in England,
to an extent some many
of these processes can be also extended
to Western Europe and so on.
But again, then we come back to this point
the Marx is quite careful about saying
that what is presenting
is not a universal history
of the emergence of capitalism.
It is the English history
of the emergence of capital.
And we may wonder why he calls this
the classical example I
think it may have to do
with the fact that in the English example
all the factors that can
contribute to a process
of primitive accumulation
basically call us together.
And we go back to this.
So first point in Marx's
argument, as I already mentioned
the existence of previous
stocks does not explain
on its own how capitalism emerged.
So Smith is not right in his account.
What is needed is also
historical process conducive
to the existence of a large mass
of what Marx calls free
labor free in a edible sense
free from a means of
production that is dispossessed
and free to sell her labor power
on the commodified on the labor market.
We will go back to this
point in the second half
of the lecture now in Marx's account
this mass of free laborers
in England was produced by centuries
long process of separation of human beings
from the conditions of
their own reproduction.
That is from land,
land that understood and
I follow here, for example
Robert Nichols understood not as basically
the ability to engage
in what Marx would call
the metabolic exchange
we measure for the sake
of (mumbles) production of social life.
So the separation from land,
it basically means the breaking
of the metabolic exchange
with nature and the separation
of the masses of people
from a direct access
to what is needed for the
reproduction of social life.
Second key point in Marx's argument
is historical process of
separation in England?
There was anything but peaceful.
It was not an ideal.
In fact, as he writes it was written
in the annals of mankind in
letters of blood and fire.
So in the chapters
on the expropriation of
agricultural population
and in the chapters on
the bloody legislation
against the expropriated Marx documents
the various processes that have led
to this outcome between let's
say, 15th and 17 18th century.
So these processes include
the foreseeable expulsion
of persons from the
land by feudal landlords
by means of extra economic
and state violence.
And they abolition of a few protections,
it's worth not even noticing here
that Marx here is not really emphasizing
let's say that evolutionary
aspect of this process
in terms of in progressive terms
on the contrary to what we may find
for example, in the 1848 manifesto
this history is really
presented as a tragedy.
So in other words (mumbles)
was an oppressive model production.
And so on it also granted some protections
to peasants access to come
to the commons granted use
in continuous use of land and so on.
So the first process in
this separation is again,
the violent forcible expulsion
from land and abolition
of feudal protections
and the consequent
progressive depopulation
of the countryside and
increase in your organization.
So large movements of
population towards cities.
The enclosure of common lands
to which peasants used to have access
for pasturage would collect it and so on.
And then a series of
bloody state legislations
meant to discipline the expropriated
and to force them to
sell their labor power
under the threat of enslavement or death.
I want to insist on this point,
because although as we will see
Marx will also say that once
in place capital is we
create the working class
that will naturalized
capitalist social relations
and be forced to work
by the silent economic compulsion.
We also need to take
into account disorder
element that has to do
with the fact that
there is nothing natural
in selling out once on
labor power, as a commodity
and people had to be forced to do this
and had to be forced to do this
by a display of an immobilization
of enormous violence.
And we'd go back to this point
because as I will argue later in fact
this disciplining of
labor also takes place
within capitalist accumulation proper.
So it is not really the case
that the silent economic compulsion
does all the work, but
we will go back to this.
Then the other elements
that Marx emphasizes
in this process are the emergence
of a class of rich farmers.
Those who survived process of expulsion
from the land, from which the class
of industrial capitalist will
arise, the growing importance
of public debt or credit in
of the modern fiscal system
which will abolish the
independence of the state
from capital and therefore
create the material conditions
for the state to become
the guardian of capital.
Quite importantly, Marx
also demystifies the story
of the industrious accumulation
of previous stocks or capital
that we find for example
is myth by stressing the role played
by colonization and
therefore by plunder robbery
and slave meant a merger in
this idyllic accumulation.
So I will share my screen again
so that we can have a look
at two passages about this.
So first passage,
"The discovery of gold
and silver in America
the extirpation enslavement,
and entombment in mines
of the indigenous
population of the continent
the beginnings of the conquest and plunder
of India and the conversion of Africa
into a present for the commercial hunting
of black skins and all things
which characterize the dawn
of the era of capitalist production.
These idyllic proceedings
are the chief moments
of primitive accumulation."
Then a second quote,
"The treatment of the indigenous
population was of course
most frightful in plantation-colonies
set up exclusively
for the export trade, such
as the West Indies, any rich
and well-populated countries,
such as Mexico and India
they were given over to plunder.
But even in the colonies
properly so-called
the Christian character
of primitive accumulation
did not belie itself."
So colonization played a crucial
role in two different ways
at least in this account.
First, the violent transfer
of immense resources
from the non non European war to Europe
either through plunder
or through enslavement
in plantation colonies
where forced labor produced
the raw materials necessary
for the development later on
industrial capital in Europe.
And colonization also provided a market
for the European emerging manufacturers.
So this is another quote.
"The colonies provided a market
for the budding manufacturers
and a vast increase in accumulation
which was guaranteed
by the mother country's
monopoly of the market,
the treasures captured
outside Europe by undisguised
looting, enslavement
and murder flowed back
to the mother country
and were turned into capital there."
Okay, so finally,
one of the aspects highlighted
by Marx as a consequence
of expropriation in separation
from the land is the end
of self subsistence
oriented peasant economy
at least as a generalized way
of reproducing social life.
Now, while formerly the
person family produce means
of subsistence and raw materials
mostly for their own consumption
the large scale farmer produces
directly for the market.
Now, Marx does not addressing
capital the consequences
of this process from the
viewpoint of the transformation
of the family and from the viewpoint
of the transformational women's
oppression under capitalism.
But this is an argument
that will be developed
by Marxist feminist and
socialist feminist orders
in especially in the 20th century
in so far, as much as
feminists will be the ones
who will fully
grasp the significance
of this transformation
and this tragedy
of this transformation in
providing an explanation
for capitalist forms of gender oppression.
So in other words, and I know
you have already listened
to Tithi Bhattacharya
on social reproduction
and so on, in other
words, one of the effects
of primitive accumulation
is the separation
between a production social reproduction
the subordination of social
production to production
which constitutes the material framework.
The social material framework
for continued gender oppression
in specifically is for
myself from this viewpoint
gender oppression is not a remnant
of a pre-capitalist past.
It actually, it continues under capitalism
but in new forms and
through new mechanisms.
So in a sense necessary dated or somebody
very logical capitalist
accumulation, at least
in terms of necessarily consequences,
Maria (mumbles) have
also famously emphasized
the direct discipline
in violence exercised on the bodies
of women within a primitive accumulation.
Maria Mies in particular insisted
on the impact of colonization
on women and women's conditions of life.
Silvia Federici focusing more
on primitive accumulation in Europe,
basically in caliber
which made the argument
that a specific process
of disciplining of women's bodies was put
in place in a specific process
of expropriation of women
from both their spheres
of expertise and a means
of subsistence that they did
have in person societies.
Now, I do not really have the
time to go into these debates.
And, but I would say just this
that while I do have reservations
on several details of the
picture articulated in particular
by Silvia Federici, including the role
of which hands in this process or the role
that Federici attributes to
the body at the same time.
I do think that her research, as well
as Maria Mies have had the
merit of poking the attention
to the way in which
primitive accumulation also
implied a deep transformation
of gender relations
and forms disciplines impacting on women.
So in other words
I do deeply appreciate
the theoretical move.
I'm not so sure about
the historical argument
and I think more historical
work needs to be done
in order to provide to offer let's say
a better historically grounded account
of the way in which primitive accumulation
actually impacted on women.
So before concluding this
first part of my lecture
and moving on now to our discussion
of the two central debates
I mentioned earlier
I would like to pause a moment once again
on an aspect that I have
mentioned at the beginning
namely Marxists on specific way
of avoiding a fall into circular reasoning
and therefore in to positing capital
as historical origin of capital.
Now from the viewpoint
of the interpretation of the
pre-history of capitalism
the motivations driving
feudal landlords, the British
the English state colonizers
in the long centuries
of primitive accumulation
cannot be the institutional capital
social relations or production
or it cannot be the creation
of a mass free laborers
because otherwise, again, we
fall into circular reasoning.
So these people were doing horrible things
but they were not doing them
because they had in mind
that the development
of a capitalist mode of production
they did them for different reasons.
Moreover, Marx must also avoid falling
into a philosophy of history
for which the emergence
of capitalism was inscribed
in some kind (mumbles) laws of linear
and progressive social development
for which necessarily we go
from antiquity to through
federalism or through capitalism
and then capitalism prepares
the grounds for communism.
So in order to avoid these
two possible mistakes
which unfortunately
later Marx did not avoid
especially the second one
Marx needs to be able to show
that contingent historical
processes due to actions
and motivation that had nothing to do
with the establishment of
capitalist social relations
or production could
that end up giving birth
to a capitalist mode of
production on a large scale.
And in fact I agree with the
analysis by Claire Roberts
in Max's Inferno about
precisely emphasizing
the different kinds
of motivations that the different actors
in this horrible play heav.
So the landlords who robbed the peasants
of feudal protections, they don't do this
in order to create a master free labor
and in to destroy based on
self subsistence economy
they do this big, in
order to basically satisfy
their own in order to cash in
in order to basically
satisfy their own self
private interest in
terms of making much more
of a revenue from the land
then what was made possible
by feudal protections.
Moreover, it is not the feudal landlords
who are the real agents of let's say
it's not the feudal landlords
who are going to develop
into industrial capitalist.
In fact, industrial capitalist imagined
from the rich farmers take advantages
of processes that are not of their making
in order to dominate
end up dominating both
landlords and (mumbles).
So in other words like
the (mumbles) we do have,
in a sense, a tragedy in this case,
more than a farce
in which there are various
actors driven by different kinds
of motivations, which do not
prefigure the final outcome
of the process
which depends ultimately
on a class struggle
on the confrontation between
feudal landlords and peasants
between rich farmers and
feudal landlords and so on
and so on.
Finally, I want to
reiterate the fact that,
and also to push back against criticism
so Marx's account of primitive
accumulation as Eurocentric.
I mean, that one could accuse
Marx of being Euro-centric
if Marx said actually
presented this history
of primitive accumulation
in England as the history
of the emergence of
capitalism that in general
as the model that would be
followed by the rest of the world
and so on, but this is not
what it's doing actually
it's quite clearly says
that is providing again
an explanation of the way
in which capital emerge
in England, in connection, obviously
with global processes,
for example, colonization
there's a slave market and
so on, but they started
with processes specific that
is focusing on is the way
in which these global
processes have coalesced
in England with all
other internal processes
of this possession and on,
and basically giving birth
to the kind of conjuncture
that would allow capitalism
to emerge in England.
So Marx is not writing a universal history
of capital or of primitive accumulation.
And in fact, he explicitly clarifies
despite at the very beginning
of his investigation of
primitive accumulation.
So I'm going to share this again.
So,
"The expropriation of
the agricultural producer
of the peasant from the soil
is the basis of the whole process.
The history of this expropriation
assumes different aspects
in different countries and
rounds through its various phases
in different orders of successions
and a different historical epochs.
Only in England
which we therefore take as our
example as its classic form.
So these two remarks on the fact
that we are not really dealing
with a universal history
of primitive accumulation
but with an example, in an example
that as Marx (muffled speaking) says
cannot be applied to other realities
because historical contingency
because historical processes
took different dynamics in different areas
of the world and the question
of the originating historical
character of primitive accumulation.
So this two remarks are going to be a key
to what I'm going to say
now, in the second section
of my lecture, starting
with the debate about
ongoing or originating
primitive accumulation.
Now, as I have already
mentioned at the very beginning
one of the worries in the
debates about primitive
accumulation was precisely that if we take
primitive accumulation as the history
is taught in pre-history of
capital as an event of the past
we may end up with a
theory of historical stages
indicating the necessarily
linear unfolding
of historical development
following the same pattern
as England and such a
theory would be incapable
of grasping the vulgaris
and local specificities
of the expansion of
capital on the worst scale
and also grasping the
role played by ongoing
dispossession in capitalist accumulation.
Now, I must say the
worry is not unjustified
because in fact, linear theological views
of transition have actually
characterized big part
of the Matis debate
characterized certainly
third international views about,
stages of development and
therefore also the order
of succession of the so-called,
(mumbles)
then the socialist revolution and so on.
This kind of theological reading
is also have characterized.
It can be found in, in different
forms in different ways
in some analytical Marxism.
So in other words, the problem is real.
The water is justified
and on a political level
this is not just a theoretical matter
because on a political level,
a certain account
of the story did have
profound consequences.
For example in the relation
of the subject blocks
to revolutionary
processes in Latin America
just to give an example.
So the political
consequences of these reading
or misreading of what Marx is doing
with the primitive accumulation
and is analysis of transition, however
political consequences
now in relation to this
first of all, the theological reading
of primitive accumulation
in my view belongs more.
Although, there are some,
let's say your selections
in the rhetoric of Marx mobilizes
in capital and elsewhere
there are some passages
that may take an escalation
lead to think that he has
a philosophy history mind.
So for example, the
past the famous passage
on negation and so on,
but at the same time
I do think that we do have
enough textual evidence
both from Capital and
from Marx’s lectors
later in life for it's
technological research.
And so on that Marx really did not think
that that his account of
primitive accumulation provided
or was meant to provide a model
for this historical developmental
capitalism elsewhere
or that there was any necessity
or there is any necessity of going through
this discreet stages of
economic and social development,
the famous letters to
(mumbles) that in recent years
have been accorded
and accorded again, show that in fact
contrary to what some critics of Marx
such as (indistinct)
think Marx did not think,
well at least certainly not the Marx
didn't really not think that we needed
to go necessarily everywhere
through capitalism
in order to achieve communism.
So it is not the case.
And in fact, again, if one reads
carefully the section eight
of a Volume I, the
level of really not only
what I would call it
really moral indignation
that much expresses at
the atrocities of entailed
by the distribution of person Techonomy
and so on.
Really do not seem to suggest
to me that he was well
at this stage in when he writes.
So not in 1848, but
when he writes Volume I
it was not really
believing that capital had
played such a laudable
progressive role in history.
And again, he's insisting on the blog
on there on the tears on
the violence and so on
Now your response these worries
some authors have basically
developed an account
of what we may call ongoing
primitive accumulation
which as I will explain,
I do not deem necessary
for you in order to address the problem
of the risk of a universal history
or the the risk of adopting England
as the necessary model
for the rest of the world.
Now, the seminar texts or reference
for this kind of theories of ongoing
of primitive accumulation is (mumbles)
the accumulation capital
written in 1913 especially
the conclusion of the texts
where (muffled speaking),
that capital has a need
for ever expanding into
non-capitalist zones.
And this need is what explains
colonialism and imperialism
the violent opening of new markets
and the violent appropriation
of resources from colonized
and dominated countries.
Now in that look, symbols
account this outside
that needs to constantly be appropriated
by capital is a geographical outside.
So this is an explanation or one
of the axis of explanation
for imperialism.
Now, recent readings of primitive
accumulation, for example
by David Harvey, most famously
but all other authors
as well, like Massimo
(muffled speaking)
and others go a step farther in the sense
that what is geographical
outside in Rosa Luxembourg
it actually becomes not even
geographically separated
from the inside anymore.
So in other words, the
outside is within capitalism
itself in this accounts
it is constantly reproduced
within capitalism itself.
It needs to be constantly
appropriated by capital.
And therefore we do have a process
of ongoing primitive accumulation.
And now we do some impossible
to give full justice
to the argument.
And I must say they are
the arguments by all those
supporting the national
ongoing primitive accumulation
not necessarily the same.
So there are differences
different accounts I'm going to focus on.
I'm going to just say a few brief words
on David Harveys on account
of what do you call
accumulation by dispossession
and just to really summarize
and simplify in a very brutal way
Harvey makes two quick key claims.
One is that accumulation by dispossession
that is ongoing primitive
accumulation is always
a background condition
for accumulation as well
as additional value and for
capitals expanded reproduction.
So we do have the
exploitation of labor power
within the black production process
and therefore the process
of what a recession of value
but we also have accumulation
by dispossession as a
constant background condition.
So what makes it possible
for value to take place?
The second main claim is that
in contemporary capitalism
accumulation by dispossession has emerged
from its background state.
So it's not a background
condition anymore.
It does become much
more salient after 1973
in order to address
capitalist crisis produced
by capitalism and ability to
continue realizing profit.
And it does become basically
the key distinctive
feature of neoliberal capitalism.
Now, in other words, in my view
what Harvey does is to
basically identify accumulation
by dispossession and
privatizing neoliberalism.
So accumulation by dispossession
and his account ends up being
equal to commodification
and privatization of land privatization
and commodification of the public services
and assets financialization
on an international scale
being the main vehicle of this processes
on other accounts of ongoing
primitive accumulation
the key aspect to be taken
into consideration is the need
of constantly rebel using
capitalist social relations
and these mantra institutions
that protect sociality
from the market.
This is for example,
Massimo De Angelis take
on primitive accumulation.
There is a constant
struggle within capitalism,
between a push to basically decommodify
or preserve areas of life
free of commodification
and so on now and violent
processes of ongoing primitive
accumulation to reappropriate
to foreclose the spaces
that are constantly opened
within capitalism.
Now, what is the problem
with these accounts?
The first problem is
that with this accounts
of ongoing primitive accumulation
we entirely lose the notion of transition.
So in other words, the
national primitive accumulation
in Marx is meant to explain,
how was it historically
possible for capital to emerge?
And this is the function
that the concept has.
From this viewpoint
primitive accumulation not
always entails this possession
but the opposite is not the case.
So in other words, this possession
or dispossession do not
necessarily entail processes
of primitive accumulation.
They can just be dispossession
and and privatization
and commodification as prompted
by the very logic of
capitalist accumulation
and by the dynamics of the struggle.
So, in other words, in some periods
you will have a much stronger
push, like the liberal period
towards privatization of
financialization and so on.
And this is in part due to the inner logic
of capitalist accumulation
the necessity of overcoming
the crisis in '73
but it also has to do with class struggle.
So in other words, the
defeat of the what is moment
of class struggle everywhere,
basically on the planet
and therefore the lesser capacity
to resist these processes.
So what I'm suggesting is that
at least in some accounts
I have in mind, for example
the Angeles here, basically the risk
is to see primitive accumulation.
Every time there is a
class struggle (chuckles)
and every time discussed
struggle is somehow lost.
And therefore, something
is taken away from us
in terms of commodification
of aspects of life.
Art is life privatizations and so on.
If we lump together
privatization and dispossession.
So basically we see every process
of dispossession or every process
of privatization we'd as basically
a primitive accumulation.
Then my fear is that we make the concept
of much emptier and
therefore more abstract
and therefore much less useful to analyze
and understand what the
concept was meant to analyze
and understand that is
the problem of transition.
Okay, so as I have already mentioned
I do not think
that we do need a national
ongoing primitive accumulation
in order to explain the
role of dispossession
of this within capitalist societies.
So the role of continuous
dispossession and so on
and we should also take
into account the fact that it is true.
The Marx basically that speak of the fact
that dispossession is reproduced
within capital and so on.
But I tend to agree with
for example (mumbles)
in thinking that what Marx
has in mind is basically
that primitive accumulation
has been sublated
within capitalism or within capitalism.
In other words, it has (mumbles)
of preserved, but in a
completely transparent way.
So it is the case that the separation
of workers from means of
production is not just the genesis
but the constant requirement
to cut that is accumulation.
And in this sense capital
accumulation does preserve
this requirement from
primitive accumulation.
So dispossession separation
from land and so on
but he presents it in largely new forms.
And to a large extent, this dispossession
is the consequences of the very mechanism
stock capital is the production.
So the way in which wage works
in other cases, it is not
it does require the intervention
of the state, but again
it requires the intervention
of an already capitalist state
within a context in which
capitalism already exist
and this is the fundamental
difference with the processes
Of primitive accumulation.
So the fundamental
difference, just to sum up
between the primitive
accumulation described
in Capital Volume I and processes
of expropriation taking place
within a capitalist society
is that these processes are a consequence
of what Marx calls the human laws
of capitalist production itself
through the centuries national capitals.
I want to add here that at least
in my own take these human laws
in order to be realized often
do require the intervention
of the state and also extra
economic compulsion and so on.
But again, as a consequence
of the drive to accumulate
the capitalist drive
to valorization of value
while as I have already
mentioned, the processes
of primitive accumulation
described in a Volume I are not
and cannot be the consequence of the logic
or in human laws of capitalist production.
Now, one may think that this
is a bit of philological
matter, or like, or maybe
a (muffled speaking)
So in other words, and it's
true that I'm a bit narrow.
So I like conceptual
qualifications and distinctions.
And I don't like maybe
because, I come from philosophy
so I like concepts to do the
work they're supposed to do
but I actually do think
that there are serious
consequences if we adopt
one view or another
because what they think characterizes
most of the the battle
stakes on ongoing primitive
accumulation and is
internalization has saved
the outside that needs to be reproduced.
What characterized, in spite
of the battle differences
is the fact that capital
ends up being conceived
as fundamentally predatory
or paracidic rather than as productive.
And my worry here is
that this really makes
capital not very different
from other modes of production
based on class relations.
While I do think
that cabinet is really
quite different from them.
And that there is in that
Marx was right on insisting
on the historical break
constituted by capital.
So, what it was my concern
is that by thinking that,
valorization of value now has, for example
being replaced by other forms
of accumulation, for example
by dispossession as the main model.
And so on what we run the risk of missing
is the central aspect
of capital as a revolutionary,
not in positive sense
expansive and global
force, which we can get
If we keep our attention
on the very logic of
capitalist production.
So the process of validation
of value, let me now
and I'm running a bit late
so I'm going to try to
make this much shorter.
Let me now go to the issue of violence.
So the second debate, and let's,
I'm going to start with
another quote from Marx
which you might view as one
of the sources of the problem.
And here Marx didn't
really do a very good job
in rhetorical terms.
Okay.
So, here this is the quote
in this comes from a passage in chapter
on the bloody legislations.
So Marx says, "The advance
of capitalist production
develops a working class
which traditional habit
looks upon the requirements
of that model production of
self-evident natural laws.
The organization of the
capitalist process of production.
Once it is fully developed
breaks down or resistance.
The constant generation of
relative surplus population
keeps the law
of the supply and demand of
labor and therefore wages
within narrow limits which
correspond to capital's
valorization requirements.
The silent, compulsion of
economic relations sets the seal
on the domination of the capitalist
over the worker that
direct extra force is still
of course used, but only
in exceptional cases.
In the ordinary run of things
the worker can be left to the
national laws of production.
That it is possible to rely
only dependence on capital
which Springs from the conditions
of production themselves is guaranteed
in perpetuity by them."
Now you can see what
the problem is, I guess.
So I take this passage to be
again, one of the main sources
of the controversy about the
role of extra economic violence
and especially the
violence of racialization
within capitalist accumulation
political Marxists
such as (mumbles) have taken to indicate
that in a logic capital is indifferent
to direct relations of domination
and compulsion such as
gender or racial oppression
and to prior social conditions and status
which he tends to level
and only use opportunistically,
moreover, one tenant
of the political Marxist system
to be that the exposition
of free labor through wages
represents the proper capitalist
class relations while Fonzo
on free labor would be exceptions
which are either exploded
opportunistically by capital
or constitute actually a
limit to capital's expansion.
So a limit that needs to be overcome.
Now, although such as
(mumbles) have remarked
that this approach
underestimates the role played
by the transatlantic slave market
new work plunder and colonialism
in capitalist accumulation
as well as the internal relation
between the lector and
ongoing racialization
with the state violence that
unavoidably a companion seat.
So for example, according
to seeing the constant differentiation
between free labor and slavery wage labor
and unpaid labor is a necessary component
of capitalist accumulation.
I would also add that this reasoning
can also be applied to gender
unpaid social reproductive labor.
So in other words, the
other side of the coin
of free wage labor is the
unpaid unrecognized gender
the ability of labor of taking place
in the household and so on and so on.
Now I do think
that we should actually
pay attention a bit more
as we have (mumbles)
to suggest to the context of this passage.
First of all, I do think
the passage is problematic.
For some reasons I am going to explain
as to the discussion at
the same time we need
to also take into account
the polemical context
in which the passage is written.
So in other words, what Marx is point,
Marx's concern here is really to emphasize
the sharp historical break constituted
by capital in relation to previous
and all other more modes of production
and he wants to emphasize
the fact that one
fundamental novelty
of the capitalist model
production is the fact
that a large amount of
despot is more compulsion
is that actually internalized
in the very worst way
in which capitalism
takes possession works.
And doesn't necessarily require
therefore the continuous
intervention of the force.
So you don't need the landlord to go
to the factory and a
friend threatened workers
through violence to force them to produce.
And so on.
Now, there is an inherent despot's market
which pertains to the market
which pertains to the condition
of being dispossessed
and therefore in a need
of selling labor power in which pertains
to the way in which the
divisional level works,
the labor process works
and so on and so on.
So he's really trying to put emphasis
on this also because I do
think that Robert is right
that one of the political targets of Marx
are basically other socialists
who basically thought
that it was possible to somehow revert
to comparative forms of
agriculture and labor,
and so on freeing labor from
the compulsionate of capital.
In other words, what I want to say
is that that Marty's point here
is that there is once this has happened.
So once the the primitive
accumulation has happened
once this mass of people
has been dispossessed
in separated from means of
production from the land
from the organic coming to
(umbles) exchange with nature
and so on, there is no
going back so we can not
really revert to a previous condition,
but without fewer lots
we need to basically think
about the alternative
on the terrain that
capital has unfortunately
created for us.
So I think this is probably one
of the reasons why Marx
is emphasizing this point
because he's basically (muffled speaking)
against the working class
(mumbles) of the competitive
and mutualistic movements, or ideas
about a return to (mumbles) production
by independent producers
as a possible response to
the emergence of capital.
And his point is that the alternative
to capital needs to be
located there at the level
of cooperation that capital
as historically developed.
Again, I must also say that.
And I insist, I mean, I'm sorry
about being a bit apologetic about Marx
but I really feel bad for
the way he is a strong man.
Very often, really there
is the reason in this idea
the reason the national debt.
Oh, great.
Again, as I said earlier, yeah,
we need (mumbles) society
through capitalism
and through this modernization and so on.
So that then we could go to communism.
This is not what Marx is saying.
What makes you say is simply
that this has happened
and this is doesn't really depend on Marx.
He does, it started really taking place.
So what do we do about this?
So once we are in this situation,
what do you do about this?
Do we fantasize about a return
to a somewhat idealized past,
do we indulge in nostalgia?
Do we fantasize about the
possibility of sociality
governed by better producers
and so on and so on, or
actually, do we want to operate
in the study circumstances that have been
(mumbles) that we are not
our making our choice.
And we try to find the potentialities
for evolution within this
contemporary circumstances.
So, in other words what
Marx wants to stress
in my view here is that
what is new in capital
and is the emergence of
impersonal mechanisms, sort
of exploitation and domination,
which can very different
from the national law
mechanisms of domination
and exploitation,
characterizing, feudal societies
or other modes, all that
kinds of class societies.
Second point, we should
also, again remember
that Marx is not offering
a universal account here
applicable to all countries in places.
And from this viewpoint,
I think the political Lamark's
reading of this point.
That pushes it is way
too far in such a way
as to make the persistent reproduction
of racial violence are across the globe,
largely unintelligible.
So in other words, we do
not, I do really do not think
that that with the theory
of indifferent capitalism,
or a theory of opportunistic
use of racial dynamics
or racial relations, we
can really make the extent
and of racialization and violence
rationalization intelligible.
So we do need the better theory than this.
So my take on this is
a very provisional one
is that while it is the
case that the emergence
of capital does require
dispossession separation
from means of production.
And it is the case that it does require
also the formational muscle free labor
through dispossession.
So free labor power that can
be purchased as a commodity.
This does not mean
that this is the only
proper capitalist form
of exploitation of labor.
And it doesn't mean that
forms of unfree labor
of slavery, forced labor,
same as slavery and so on
can not be intertwined or not seen
in a continual on upon more or less
than I continue on with
the free wage labor.
Why, because Marx is that insisting
on the fact that we need to pay attention
to the local history, so
primitive accumulation.
So in other words, the way historically
capital has fallen within a society.
Also inflects the form that
a capitalist accumulation
will take within that society.
So what I would suggest here
is that we may understand
let's say in terms of violence, somehow
we may understand that let's
say the legacy of the different
stories of primitive accumulation
as basically an ongoing afterlife
of primitive accumulation
within capitalist societies.
And here I'm using the term
by Ron Jeffy in a forthcoming paper.
So in other words, we do not need to have
a national ongoing primitive
accumulation to explain
the use of extra economic
violence and racialization
because we can just pay
attention as Marx was inviting
us to do to the local
histories of capital formation
and transition to capital
in different countries.
And to the way in which the genesis
the localist the history of
genesis remains inscribed
in the form that capitalism
takes in a given country.
So, for example, we could think that
in a settler colonial countries,
such as the United States
otherwise colonized
countries, racial violence
and differentiation has being absorbed
and superseded by the very functioning
of a capitalist accumulation,
it has been transformed.
And it does come to
play a constitutive role
for the very working of capital.
So not just to simplify this, I mean
if we take the very simple logic,
I need (mumbles) abstract level
we could say capital doesn't really
need is indifferent to
racial differentiation.
Doesn't really need racism in
the United States to survive.
We could replace differentiation
among the level force through other forms
of social differentiation and so on.
I find this absolutely
unhelpful where you're looking
at capital because capital
is not a logical creature
is not a logical entity.
It's not a concept.
It is a historical reality
that we try to grasp
with the concept that through
a set of concepts and so on.
So from this viewpoint,
the historical genesis
does play a role
in the way in which capillary
is smarter than unfolds.
And now, while on a logical
level, I can imagine all sorts
of things insofar as they
are not contradictory.
So to the extent I'm
not contradicting myself
I'm getting imagine all sorts
of logical possibilities
for capital on I started gold level
which is what should matter to us
have you or capital in United States
without racism much seems
to me, not very credible.
So in other words
I really don't see how this
could historically happen
which doesn't mean that it
necessarily will not happen
major it could fall
on our head and change
conditions for everybody.
And also the conditions
for capital accumulation
history is made of contingencies
not on a strict necessities
or really iron laws
but it is quite unlikely.
And on on analytical and political level
I would say that this is what matters.
It is the disease
historically very unlikely
because a racist plays a constitute role
within US capitalism and so on.
So just to conclude in
a word, and I'm sorry
for running so late, I probably
was a bit too ambitious
in what I wanted to do with this lecture
but just to conclude
the last what I would like to say
about this is that I do think,
and again, my own ideas about this
are not entirely fleshed out
but I do think that the
real challenge here is to
on the one hand preserve
primitive accumulation
as an originating concept of story.
So it's the story or the multiple stories
of the transition to capital
while at the same time
making extra economic violence
under capitalism intelligible
and not exceptional as
Marx in that (mumbles)
passage claims because this
is not exceptional at all.
And while at the same time,
also seeing that the way
in which the various processes
of racialization enslavement
violent dispossession and so
on today have an eminently
capitalist forms and as such driven
in or caused by the
necessities of capitalism
valorization of value,
that is capital production.
So in other words, the challenge
for me is to basically try to
hold on this view of the core
or capital being valorization
value while at the same time
being able to give an
account vocabulary that takes
into account all the contingent messy ways
in which capital actually
works in different socialities
without therefore replacing
historical realities
with the neat logical concepts.
- Beautiful, thank you very much.
We will have a huge round
of a virtual applause for your talk.
We appreciate it also
giving it in this format
and taking us really to
the end of capital Volume I
right at the end of the series
which is a neat logical conclusion.
I'm gonna ask people to put
their questions in the chat.
If they have them, maybe I'll start
out with a question if you don't mind.
So just a brilliant presentation
of a problem that I
think is not restricted
to the primitive accumulation
chapter, but it is a problem
or a question of the project as a whole.
And I wanna ask you about it.
That is the problem of the
establishment of a system
with a lot of internal
necessity in a non-system
or a mixed set of systems that
are governed by contingency
if you can say that are not governed
suddenly you have a governed system.
So I wanted to ask you, and I think
you wanna preserve that moment?
And I think that's really good
there's distinction in terms
of that comes from Benny
I mean, I don't know
exactly where he got it
but you could call the difference
between the two primitive
accumulations system
forming violence and system
maintaining violence.
And it's a good idea to keep them separate
I think for analytic reasons.
But if you look at the
system as an interpretation
rather than a description
of some historical facts
I can see why some readers
of Marx would want to keep
primitive accumulation going,
and I'll just present this to you
and you can tell me what you think of it.
It's a question really of
how well it gets established
or of how total the system is
or whether the system
is a logical totality
or a historical totality.
And if you keep primitive
accumulation going
you picture a system that
is not fully established
and that has to constantly
reestablish itself.
And so you open up sites
of resistance without reifying the system.
I can see why that would be appealing.
So the question to you
would be what happens
to revolutionary possibilities
if we don't, if we think
of capital is something
that really is this blood
thirsty machine that really has taken over
that is as completed as
you're presenting it to me.
- Yeah I'm not sure.
So I'm not sure we need...
So I agree with this with the worry.
And I also agree
with the idea that in
fact, not everything under
within capitalism is subsumed
under a single logic.
And there is a big danger in thinking
in the startups precisely because then
it becomes really unclear
how resistance is possible
but it also gives a very, in my view
a very impoverished view
and account of our lives.
So in other words, there is a lot, I mean
our lives have constrained
by capital clearly.
We live in within us,
very rigid constraints unless we are rich
independent rich but
within this constraints
there is a lot that goes
on that is not reducible
to capitalism logic tool,
which is our life
people are not objects that
can be completely subsumed
and so on.
So I completely agree with the worry
but my question is why
do we need a national
ongoing primitive accumulation
to make this point?
So we can make this point
by speaking about the fact
that capitalism is a social
relation is not a thing.
And so it's a social relation
it's a classic relation and
a classic relation (mumbles)
so in other words they are
predicated upon antagonism
and conflict.
And the outcome
of conflict is never a given
who these are precisely
because it is the outcome war
or conflict that has to take place
or is taking place and so on.
And this means that there is
clearly a constant struggle
within capitalism, against commodification
to protect, areas of
life from commodification
for public services
to lower the rate of
exploitation and so on and so on.
But the issue is why do we
need a national primitive
accumulation ongoing
primitive accumulation
to make this point
in from this viewpoint
The risk is actually to then take for good
a reified national capital as a thing,
or as I know infrastructure
and so on rather
than a set of social relations
and therefore another
so solve the problem created
by this view of capital.
We need to postulate these outsides.
Let's say that constantly reappropriated
through ongoing primitive
accumulation but the problem
in my view is using the
conception of capitalism
as decertified thing, rather
than what Marx says it is
that you see social
social relation is sold
to the people relating to each other
in a mediated way and so on and so on.
And if this means that capitalism
capital societies that are messy
they don't work like machines.
There are gaps and cracks
in their production
that they are filled with conflict.
And this was precisely
by the way, Marx's wager
possessing they're potentially filled
with conflict and so on.
So again, I agree with
the worry, I don't think
the national ongoing
primitive accumulation
is the solution, unless we are
speaking about transitions.
So in other words, unless
we are really speaking
about socialities parts
of the world that have not
been subsumed under the
capitalist mode of production yet
and they are now undergoing
a natural process
of primitive accumulation
that is fundamentally
transforming class
relations in that sociality.
So, replacing the previous class relations
with new class relations.
(muffled speaking)
- In one way, I hear in what you're saying
there is already a word
from Marx for the way
capital's internal outside
let's say gets absorbed.
And that's an assumption.
That's not primitive accumulation
and there are different modes
of subsection and they change
and they have their own
transitions to thank you,
that's a really useful answer.
I want to see if there are so far
there are no questions in the chat.
This is how we've been
having like flagging energy
among the audience as the
semester wides to an end.
But if anyone wants to ask a question
please do so I could
ask you another question
a more historical question.
If you don't mind.
- I don't know if I can answer it (laughs)
- No it's more about a theory of history
as you were trying to think it through.
And that is about how could this emerge?
How could the system
that is very different
in the way it regulates itself emerge
out of something that was more
or less just traditional had its own force
and modes of domination
in it say feudalism
but wasn't machinic in this way.
How do you describe, how do you think
of the conjuncture that allows capitalism
to arise in England?
Is it just a contingency?
Like when does the necessity take hold?
When does logic become the new mode?
How does it happen that out
of a bunch of contingencies
somethings should take shape
that forbids contingency
in a way or that subsumes all
contingencies or tries to?
- Yeah, yes (laughing)
I mean, I'm sorry
- What's your answer?
That's what I wanna know
- Yes like it is, I mean of
course, there is the other line
or interpretation of the
issues of transition.
So, which is the
contradiction between forces
of production in relations of production
as basically governing the
logical historical development
and unfolding and so on.
And I think it's wrong.
Yeah, I think is wrong.
And so this is the aspect
of political Marxism
I actually agree with.
That basically transitional
was decided by (mumbles)
automatically and therefore, yes,
it was a contingent outcome
which produced a level degree.
It is a contingent outcome.
It doesn't really mean contingency
but it does produce a mode of production
that pauses constraints
extremely rigid constraints
on socialities in human life.
And more than other modes of production
in which you have that
domination in the feudal system.
Of course you have exposition song,
but to a large extent,
peasants were basically living the life
and didn't really care
about who was the King.
So this is a clearly, it's
not now a predicament anymore.
And also capital has also created,
through the global market,
a level of interconnection
on a global level that makes
really this constraints
global and operating
at different levels in
different societies.
But I do think this was
the product and the outcome
of that mentality, contingent
historical process.
There is no history doesn't do anything.
So there is no secret puppeteer
or governing the logic
of history and so on.
- Thanks.
Okay, we have a couple of questions
in the chat and can we go to Brendan Rome?
Audrey, would you open Brendan's mic?
Hi Brendan.
- Yes, thank you
for a wonderful and informative talk.
My question was about, so
in Volume II when Marx talks
about capital tolerating,
no space barriers.
I was wondering how the dynamic
of both the need for
a geographic expansion
A subsection in primitive accumulation
with colonialism interplays
with kind of a contradiction
of the need to enclose and
kind of build a critical mass
a foreign industrial proletariat
in order to sort in the
cycle of accumulation
for industrial capital?
- Okay.
Can you repeat the question
Sorry, because I'm not sure I got there.
- So my question was about
kind of the often contrary dynamics
of space in what's necessary for capital.
And there's the (indistinct) expansion
of finding new resources, new markets
and also the necessary kind
of searching or contraction
of space in order to kind
of sorts in the labor
the capital cycle in the way, kind of
in a industrial proletariat was
kind of a mask from the land
and closers in like cities
like Manchester, Leeds.
So I was wondering how that kind
of contradictory dynamic paints
in primitive accumulation in your view.
- Okay, so I'm not sure.
Okay, I mean, I think
in the (mumbles) says that is this passage
in Marx about the negation of space
or space or rational
space by means of time.
So in other words, one of the features
of capital has been precisely
the development of forms of
communication, transportation
and seclusion of commodity and people
and so on that would basically
annihilate space in a sense
like reduce space by means of time.
So in other words, by
accelerating processes,
trains first and then in railways
and so on, then flights, (mumbles)
and now even the internet
and they all logistics
sector and it's organization.
So I do think, I mean
I do think to come back also to the issue
of capitalism totality and so on,
it's precisely that the
somehow capital takes
or tries to hold together
precisely different temporalities
and processes for different natures
which is also what makes it necessary.
Some, often and not as exceptionally
as much thought the intervention
of the state to basically help
violently coordinate and organize all
of this different discrepant temporality.
So I don't think this
is a very precise answer
to your question, but the
point I'm trying to make is
that if we'd take, into account,
if we take a capital
to be not a very well-organized modality
not an harmonic one, not
an expressive one and so on
but totality contradictory
processes that need often
to be violently record united.
And so for example, through crisis
and so on and so on, I think
we are in a better position to answer
these kinds of questions.
So how basically distinct
processes could take place more
or less at the same time.
Yeah, now I will stop here
because I don't want to
be too long, I don't know
if I really addressed your question.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, okay.
Let's go now to Tamara Vukov.
Could we open Tamara's mic.
Tamara if you want to present
your question, be terrific.
- Hi I didn't expect to be on screen
but thank you for the wonderful talk.
And yes, I was interested
in hearing maybe a bit more about you.
You talked at one point about the notion
of the ongoing afterlives
of primitive accumulation.
I think you referenced
someone's work in particular
and I thought that was
interesting in terms
of some of the nonlinear
temporalities that that could imply
and how you might distinguish that from
some of the more overly
generalized conflations
that you described
of dispossession of primitive accumulation
dispossession of the works
of Harvey, et cetera.
And I think you indicated a
little bit when you talk more
about local histories
and specific processes
of transition going on
but it just be interested
to hear you speak
about that a bit more.
- Yeah, so first of all,
the national after life was such,
they came from an article
that is (mumbles) by Aaron Jaffe.
So it's not my own nice
wording, unfortunately
I wish it was.
Yeah so, I mean, the
idea is basically again
when we speak about afterlife
and I think this is also the way
in which I don't Jeffy
understands it in this paper
when we speak about afterlife
we are not speaking about anachronisms.
So in other words is not after life
in the sense of anachronistic eminence
of the pre-capitalist past or the period
of transition that then can
or cannot be overcome by
subsequent development and so on.
So for example, to go back to the question
of racial oppression in United States
this is not an algorithm
that remains within
a capitalist society that
otherwise would privilege
undifferentiated free labor and so on.
This is probably capitalist's phenomenon
but it is also legacy in
the sense and afterlife
of the way in which transition worked
within in the United States and so on
and how capitalist was formed there.
So by afterlife, I think what
we should mean is the fact
that again, the genesis
of capital remains inscribed
in the very categories
and mechanisms or capital
over the course of its development
and not as an anachronism
or not as a remnant
of the past and not as
a ghost from the past
but as something that is
subsumed by the very form
of capital in a given
situation, this applies
for me to racial violence,
racial oppression
but it applies also to gender.
So in other words, while
it is the case that gender
oppression clearly predates
capitalism, at least in on.
So they released are yours to take gender
oppression today to be over
fundamentally different
and not to be a remnant of millennia
of gender oppression,
but to actually have a dynamic produced,
reproduced inflected by capital itself.
So, in this case, so from this viewpoint
even if we take, for example
Federici's point about
primitive accumulation
having also not just
Federici's point, actually
Marxist feminist point about the way
in which the separation of production
from social reproduction
has created the framework
for the contemporary form
of gender oppression.
So on, and of course
the separation happened
through primitive accumulation
Again, this doesn't mean that
if we call it this an afterlife
or primitive accumulation
it doesn't mean that is an anachronism
or just a ghost of the past.
It means that it is an element
of the genesis or capital that has become
constitutive feature or vocabulary self.
- Thank you Tamara.
Okay I'm gonna turn to Paul Reitter
who has a question Paul?
You're muted, honey, we
don't hear you at all.
Come on in, open up your mic.
- Thank you.
Yeah, how many more times
is that going to happen?
Probably a lot anyway.
Sorry, thanks so much for the talk,
which I think picked up
in a really productive way
on the debate that we heard last week
where Michelle Heinrich and Fred Mosley
they were talking about,
of course, a related issue
but not primitive accumulation.
But we had contrast
in reading styles where
one person was really
emphasizing very heavily
what Marx said, literally.
And then the other person was talking more
in terms of what the
text seems to be doing
and what is necessary to add
into this for it to really
make sense, given what's there.
And in a way, it seems
in the debate that you set up
between yourself and others
that there's an element of that going on
that people are getting
hung up on certain moments
in Marx that don't
necessarily apply so well
to what seems to be happening
in this primitive
accumulation section elsewhere
in the text.
Obviously there is talk
about the laws of history
which is one of the things
that leads people to take this
to read this teleology
out of Marx late later on.
And this kind of brings me to my question
which has to do with terminology.
I'm wondering what you think the role
of the particular term primitive
has been in the fostering
some of the misreading that you're you
you described here,
it's part of the debate of course, itself.
People have argued about
whether that's the best translation.
There's a fairly recent essay article
on it by the anthropologist,
Rosalyn Morris.
Maybe you're familiar with it
which makes us (mumbles)
to make a strong case
against primitive accumulation
against translating (mumbles)
which has as a primitive.
And so I think I'll let it rest there.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And I didn't mention this
question of how to translate
(mumbles)
One could translate it as
originality or original or,
but I'm not sure that
much really interested
on the term, sorry, was
maybe because I'm not.
So in other words first of all, I do think
that that primitive was
chosen translation in French
in sovereign this view point.
It is not, the problem,
then it would be how Marx
himself understood strongly
because it was not just like
a mistaken translation by somebody else.
And I mean, I'm not sure, I mean
I really don't think
that the problem is the term.
So in other words, in the sense
that what the term means (mumbles)
is German form or English
or Italian translation
which is also medieval
and so on in most cases.
Is this a national of
originating accumulation?
So in other words, the
fact that we are speaking
about a genesis sorta story of genesis
and I think I did, this
is the real problem
for scholars who are or Marx
who have been worried about
the risk of falling into
universal history laws
or theological history
and so on rather than the term itself.
So in other words
even if we change, revert change primitive
into original accumulation
I don't think this will
do anything to address.
I'm not sure this will
do something substantial
to address what the where the worry lies
in the sense that I
think they really, really
the crux of the matter is precisely
whether we want to take this as a story
about the genesis or not as a
study about transition or not
whether we call it primitive
whether we call it originating
whether here we call it original or what
primary I'm not sure so much
really depends on the chosen translation.
So the reason why I
didn't mention and maybe,
like I'm not very sensitive to rhetoric,
but the reason why I
didn't mention this issue,
which is the, one of the most
frequently mentioned issues
how to translate and why are
you saying so-called (mumbles)
why, and the reason why
I didn't mention this
at the beginning of the lecture,
and didn't make a point
about how to translate
or strongly is that I do
not think that the issue
of how to translate this term
solves the conceptual problems
and the conceptual
controversies that I mentioned
maybe I'm wrong-
- And that's not where
I was going with that.
I mean, I do think that
it does bear on the kinds
of debates that you were
talking about or original.
I mean, it's not only the case
these terms are they have
different connotations
so (mumbles) having a kind
of positive connotation
primitive having sort of the opposite.
But I think also more
important or more relevant
for this discussion would be that
primitive really does try to
push something into the past.
Whereas the, the original moments
it's easier to think of it
as persisting in a
certain way, I would say.
And that it may not has come up
in the debates about this.
I'm not claiming, originality
for this interpretation,
but that does make some sense to me
on the other hand, I
don't want to seem like
a narcissistic translator
who thinks that, like if you just tweak
the translation, little (laughter)
all the problems will be solved,
that's definitely not the case.
- Yeah, no I mean,
no, I don't want to downplay the role
of translations also
because as you mentioned,
the beginning, this is also part
of my work and how I translate a sentence
from predominance really changes the mean,
it can actually change the
meaning of the so I agree, sorry.
i didn't want to downplay this issue,
but and I do think
that a new English
translation is actually needed
because there are some issues
that, but at the same time
I'm not so sure that that
so much weight can be given
to a single term for the reason.
I mean, again, which is
the Marx himself chose
because he chose, he accepted
it for the French translation.
So, again, since this is not,
I dunno angles on intervention
or a mistranslation by,
but it is actually Marx thought
that that was strongly could
be translated as primitive.
- All right I mean, but
there's also the question
of what that meant in French in 1874
and what that term has meant in English,
in the last 70 or, or 80 years.
And just, I mean
there is obviously the problem
in translation of something.
Like, I think I talked about
this at one point earlier
so I'm apologizing for repeating
myself (laughs) in this series
but just how the appearance
of proximity can sometimes
be misleading of course.
And just because it
looks, you know, very much
like primitive doesn't necessarily mean
that it lines up semantically
at this point that well
because a lot has happened
in the language since then.
- Yeah, no on this, I agree.
This may be, I understand the concern
about this and why at the
same time again, but I mean
this leads us really to,
like what the different meanings
and maybe we should let
to cope with this fact.
So (chuckles) like
polysemantic nature of words
but they don't, I mean,
I'm not worded to date
so what I want to
clarify, like if we think
that in fact, given the
law that the character
of the history of the world primitive
it would be better to
avoid in order this term
in order to avoid
misunderstanding my fun with this.
And so I do think that, yeah
there may be a good
idea to not to translate
as primitive anymore, but
to translate as original.
But again, this would be
just in consideration.
But if I can make an example though,
so in other words, again,
I think will not be a problem at all.
It can be (muffled speaking)
It can be in different ways
precisely because words
have, semantic anyway.
But the look at like if we
start with this then look
at the way in which the distinction
between productive and
non-productive labor has caused a lot
of misunderstandings,
stomachaches and bad mood
against Marx within the
feminist socialists debate.
So in other words, in again
why this is the case because people here
I'm productive in relation
for example, I'm paid
I'm waged social (mumbles)
labor here, I'm productive.
And think that there is some kind
of value judgment entailed in the world.
But in fact, there isn't
at all the issue is that simply
the formal level that doesn't
produce directly value
but contributes to the creation
and the conditions for
the generational value
surplus value and its exploitation.
Now, how do we go about that?
Do we get rid of the
distinction of (mumbles)
in order to avoid this semantic problems
and replace it with something else,
or we try to maintain the fact that yes,
words have a history.
They also have different applications
in different contexts used
in different ways and certain songs.
This is a more general, I mean, it goes
beyond the issue of original
(muffled speaking) primitive.
I'm just mentioning this because
I do have a general worry
about some kind of fantasy
about the diversity of
language that we should drop.
(laughter)
- All right, very good point.
Well, go back to the chat
and time is getting short.
So I'm gonna admit one more question
apologies to those whose
questions come after this.
- Yeah, so okay.
Just to re explain clear terms
what I tried to say earlier,
but in more confused terms.
I think the passage in Marx
where is he speaks about the fact that,
extra economic compulsion is
an exception song is wrong.
In what sense in the
sense that on the one hand
it does capture an aspect of capitalism
which is the fact that a fair amount
of compulsion is directly internalized
in the very working of
capitalistic possession and so on.
However it is.
So from this viewpoint
there is a big difference
between feudalism, for example
or at the no slave production
in the Roman empire and capitalism.
So this, and I want to really
maintain this distinction
at the same time while it is true
that there is this enormous
amount of compulsion
and despotism internalized
by the very economic
working capital itself.
It is also not the case
that the use of extra economic
force is an exception.
It is simply not the case.
It was not the case in England where Marx,
not just during, the period
of regional accumulation
of primitive accumulation.
It was not the case in the
moment in which Marx was writing
extra economic violence did do a lot
of work and it is historically
not the case anywhere.
So in other words, and
why is this the case?
Because people are not
happy to be exploited.
I mean, I'm sorry to simplify
in this, in this time.
So not, but this is really what matter.
So in other words, people resist
and fight and so on they
don't do this always
or always with success, but
they're not once you come
to rely on the labor power of this,
on people's labor power and so on
through that fixed
possession it's to there
and you have to deal with it
you know with the little problem
that this is liberal power
is a very strange commodity
because it's attached to a living being
and this living being possibly
has a history as agency
as kinship relations,
friendships communities,
and so on all elements that can contribute
to processes of class
formation and resistance.
And there, of course you need the state
the economic violence of the state,
not only it is.
And I would also say that
and I must say we have Claire
Roberts gives an explanation
of this passage in which
she basically in general
over the decision economic
violence, basically suggesting
that what Marx wants to
indicate is more the distinction
between what is directly capital's agency.
And what is the capital state agency.
So once capital is in place
so of course there is
extra economic violence
but capital is not the
agent of this violence
it is the state.
And so we need to distinguish
between these two forms
of agencies, but this doesn't
really solve the problem
that means smart and reading of the smart
charitable reading of the
passage and of the problem
but it doesn't solve the real issue
because on historical level
it is also not true
that capital doesn't exercise
that extra economic violence.
He actually did, the
building of the railways
in United States.
So in other words, capitalist
companies, historical
in parts of the world, but
also today can actually
exercise directly violence
when they're able to
when they don't need the
state to do the work for them
when they're allowed to do it
with impunity and so on and so on.
So this is part of the way
in which capital works.
So from this viewpoint, I do think that
we need to understand that passage,
we need (mumbles) context and
therefore downplaying a bit
the rhetoric of the passage
and I agree with Roberts
about this at the same time.
I do think that there is also a problem
in any case thinking
that extra glomming
violence is a phenomenon
of capitalist society
by the capitalist state
but not to capital itself,
because it's historically false
sorry and Marx has to deal with history.
So in other words, we may become
enamored with our concepts
but if it didn't work historically like
if they are actually
contradict historical evidence
then we may need to revise it.
And we may need to think in that case
that this was not one of
Marx's most felicitous passages
because it does lead to
fundamental misunderstanding.
So again,
to reframe the issue, I would say
what Marx considers
as exceptional circumstances
are much less exceptional
in the sense that if precisely
because capitalism doesn't work
as this harmonious machine
but it's actually a mess
in which there is conflict.
Then the exception.
I'm not saying that the
exception is the rule
but the exception is basically a there.
So in other words, this need of violence
and forced and compulsion
is always there for, in that
it is not the case that the
silent economic compulsion
can do the whole job.
So the market alone
doesn't do the whole job.
- We have to make a seizure here.
I'm afraid.
And thank the people
in the chat whose
questions weren't answered
for great questions that are
there and need to be addressed.
And the people who did
not ask their questions
for keeping the conversation
at the highest level.
Thank you, Professor Arruzza.
I think the most stimulating possible end
to a really interesting really,
and you brought us around
through the true Marx to the moments
of critique that we need
to exercise against him.
So I appreciate that.
I wanna thank you.
I wanna thank everybody else
for sticking with us and
working through this text again
in different ways with all the people.
And we'll give a round of
applause virtually to you
Professor Arruzza for your talk (claps)
Thank you.
- Very much.